(upbeat music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week, at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna talk about coinkydinks.
- Yeah, we asked you,
what was the exact wording
of the question?
- I don't know.
I don't have it in front of me.
Have you experienced a
mind-blowing coincidence,
a set of circumstances
that are inexplicably wild?
Like somethin' you just can't,
it's a coincidence beyond explanation.
And then my kind of followup question is,
and what did you do about it?
Like how did it impact your life?
I don't know, you just hear
stories of people who were like,
well, we lived in different countries
and then, well I did hear this story.
- All right.
- This was the inspiration
for the question.
I just happened to be listening
to talk radio a while back.
And there was some story about
this couple whose parents,
I think the guy was like,
he fought in the Vietnam War
and he met and fell in love
with a woman over there.
And then they almost got
married and then they didn't,
and then there was no contact at all.
And then years later
their kids got married.
And then they realized
that their parents almost got married.
Of course if they did, they
never would have existed.
- Right and them getting married
would have been really weird.
- That's crazy though.
And I remember, we devoted a
whole episode of GMM to that.
We set a balloon, we
put a note in a balloon-
- There's an incredible story about-
- Incredible story.
- And I don't remember the details.
- We don't need to
rehash it 'cause it was-
- It's a balloon that went in the air
and did some crazy things.
- So we asked you-
- Brought people together
in a really crazy way.
- For your amazing coincidence that-
- Now, lemme just say before we-
- Oops.
- Before we get started
that we don't have any balloon stories.
- I thought you were 're gonna say,
before we get started, we
don't believe in coincidences.
- I'm just gonna-
- Everything happens
for a reason.
- I'm just gonna say that-
- And we can talk about that.
- I didn't know exactly what to expect.
I'm not saying that-
- My hopes were high.
- I'm not saying that these
stories are not amazing,
especially to the people
who experienced the things.
- But they did not meet my expectations.
(both chuckle)
- No, I think that-
- I mean the story I just shared
about the couple that didn't get married-
- We didn't really get one of those.
- Get married.
Yeah, y'all didn't give us one of those.
- Well, but I think that-
- So what we're sayin' is
you know what?
Scroll through your podcast,
if there's somethin' else
that you were like almost about to choose-
- No, I actually have a point.
That's not, that's not-
- Stick with us.
- Gonna encourage them to
like make things up next time.
And that is, coincidences are significant
because they are uncommon.
Coincidences are significant
because they are rare.
It is not every day that you find out
that the parents of you and
your spouse almost got married
in a foreign country.
You are reacting weird
to what you just did.
- I'm sorry.
Well, I was tryin' this new type of coffee
that you pour a little coffee
in the bottom, a concentrate
and then I added cream and
then I added hot water.
And I think it stratified.
Because I just drank enough of the coffee
to realize that I have
not been drinking anything
but creamer and water.
- Well, that's not bad.
- Well, it's gonna be-
- Do you need to stir it
with your fingers?
- Quite a grand finale.
I was lookin' for
somethin' to stir it with.
I looked at your finger.
Looked back at my finger.
- Stir it with your finger.
- I looked at the Mythical comb here.
- Kind of an early promo.
- I don't wanna do that because-
- You could stir it with the
back of the Mythical brush.
- You know what, I'm just gonna drink it.
It'll stir up in my stomach.
- Okay.
- I apologize.
- All I was saying is
that I'm not surprised
that every single person who
listens to "Ear Biscuits"
and chose to contribute a coinkydink story
doesn't have some mind-blowing thing.
Because if everybody experiences it,
it would be absolutely, absolutely,
it wouldn't be mind-blowing anymore.
- It would be normal.
- Our minds would just
be blown all the time.
And then everybody is like,
"Ah, big deal, big deal."
- That would just be the wind.
- But for me, this is
more a study in what,
when you just ask an average person,
what is their most
significant coincidence?
It's like, oh, I see how that
is really significant to you.
I don't necessarily know if this
is gonna be featured on NPR.
I also think that we can
determine whether or not
these are just random coincidences
or actual magic occurred.
- Oh!
- Because I feel like
we could be authoritative about that.
- Okay, so is it a coinkidink,
a full-blown coincidence,
or just unequivocally magic.
- Yeah, yeah, right.
- And when we say magic, that's
just a general umbrella term
that don't read too much into that.
That could mean is the universe
tryin' to tell me something?
Is this a personalized message from God?
- Was it orchestrated?
- Yes, yes.
Or as you would say, was it orgastrated?
- Orgastrated, yeah.
- Or was it just coincidental.
- Hit it.
- Let's get started with Laura Carlyle.
"I've been with my partner four years
and we constantly find
ourselves saying the same thing
with the same inflection at the same time.
For example, I'll be
thinking of something random
that has no correlation to him.
Like, hmm, I wonder how snails mate.
And next thing, he starts a conversation
on how snails have sex.
Is it coincidence?
Have we just got so close?"
- Let's not call it snail sex.
Let's stick with the word mate.
When it comes to snails.
I just don't think it's
dirty enough to call it sex.
And I celebrate that
there's a dirty side to sex.
- I imagine that snail
sex is especially dirty.
Have you ever like
looked at a snail trail?
- Slimy's not dirty.
- Says you.
- Hey, they don't need any
external lube, I guess.
Boy, we've done it.
- "Have we got so close
we are becoming one?
Or are we unknowingly
communicating silently,
Like the way trees communicate
and share with each other
through tiny fungal
threads under the soil?"
Well first off-
- I like you Laura.
- I can answer your
question at the end there.
Unless you see-
- Laura's not afraid
to talk about snails, sex,
or tiny fungal threads.
- Unless you see, now first of
all what she's talkin' about
is this, this is incredible,
what they have discovered
about these fungal
networks that communicate,
that trees communicate with each other.
Several podcasts, news reports, articles
have been written about
this by this point,
about this by this point.
And the idea that trees
communicate with each other
and share resources and
the tree that is in need
of more sunlight will communicate with one
that has gotten more nutrients.
And it's all being done
through these fungal networks-
- Which are the largest
living organism on the planet.
- There is one that is considered to be,
I guess in terms of just like, wow area.
If you do not see fungal threads
attached between you and your partner,
then I'm assuming that that
is not what is happening.
- Incidentally, that is how snails mate.
- Fungal threads?
(Link chuckles)
Because they're so slow.
- It was a joke, Rhett.
I'm not gonna actually, I
can't defend my statement.
- Well, I actually, but no,
is that what makes it a funny joke?
(both chuckle)
'Cause they're so slow.
Like fungus has time to
grow on them while they're-
- Either you thought it, it was more of a,
like it felt funny, than it thought funny.
- Well, I think it's actually still funny
the more you think about it.
- Bonus.
- This is not magic.
I'm just gonna go ahead and
say that right off the top.
This is not magic.
This is just being-
- If you're thinking about something-
- In the same place-
- And then somebody brings something up,
there's somethin' that
neither one of you have seen,
have identified that you've
both been exposed to.
So it's a coinkidink, you know, it's like,
you weren't talking about
it and it wasn't obviously,
you're not both lookin' at snails mating.
Or one snail that's lonely.
But at some point you were
both exposed to snails
in such a way that something then-
- A sexy snail.
- Sexy snail.
And then something triggered
it in each of your minds,
at the same time.
So on a subconscious level,
you were subconsciously triggered
by somethin' snail sex related.
That then when you have the thought
and he had, and then
you made the statement.
You're not drawin' it back to
the connection but it's there.
It's under the roots, it's in the soil.
- And I do believe-
- Good analogy.
- That snails, otherwise
known as escargot,
when they are eaten by the French-
- Leave it to you to consider everything
in its final food form.
- They are an aphrodisiac.
- Huh?
- I don't know if that's true
or not, but it feels right.
- You're tryin' to take
my joke thing and just-
- No, no, no, this is not a joke.
- Exactly, you're tryin'
to assert somethin'
in the same way that I make a joke.
I bet you it'll just feel funny.
- No.
- I betcha,
what you said feels right,
but if you think about it,
it doesn't make sense.
- Okay, I'm just giving
a plausible explanation
for this specific coincidence.
And that is-
- Already did that.
- You guys were.
No you didn't give a plausible,
specific explanation.
You said you experienced, I'm saying-
- Give me an example.
- I'm saying what they
experienced specifically
that led to this conclusion.
And that is they were watching a program,
it was a television show, call
it program in some places.
- Okay.
- And it was about, it
was a nature documentary.
And there was something,
not a snail but something snail-like,
like a slug that makes most
people think of snails,
that was featured.
They both watched that-
- Right, they did.
- Between 48 and 72 hours
before this coincidence.
Then the second thing that happened was,
they both saw something
about French cuisine
and somebody said somethin'
and in a long list of things
that were aphrodisiacs
escargot was an aphrodisiac.
Or could just be something as simple
as they had watched a nature documentary.
And then when they were in
separate rooms, they began,
as partners often do, began to think about
what would it be like
to have sex right now?
Oh, maybe we should have sex.
That's one of the things that happens
when you are in a relationship-
- When you're sexually active.
- When you're sexually active,
is like, well, maybe we
should have sex right now.
- We should activate sexually right now.
- And so those things got jumbled up
in the way that they get
jumbled up in your mind
before a dream.
And they just happened to
happen at the same time.
I mean, nothin' to write home about here.
It's just kind of cool that you guys
are in sync with each other.
- Maybe it's a pandemic thing.
But I definitely have seen
there's more of that dynamic.
It's like, ah, what am I gonna do now?
I'm at home, like I've always been,
with the same people I've always
been, one of 'em's my wife.
- This is your thought process.
- We could have sex.
- Hmm.
That's how your brain works?
- And then I send her an email.
- From a different part of the house?
- That's how we set it up.
- Okay, it's very formal.
- It's like that way, you
know, it's like you gotta both,
you gotta sync your wavelengths.
That's best done through email.
I call it a naughty gram.
- I would think that texting
works better in this scenario.
- No, it's not formal enough.
- Okay, well, my dad always
ends his texts with, love dad.
Like with a salutation, is
that what they call that?
Is the salutation the beginning?
- Sign off.
- There's an official-
- Where we goin'?
- I'm just sayin' that you
can make a text very formal.
You can say dear Christy.
- Oh!
- I'm in the other room.
- Thinkin' maybe we should-
- Have sex.
Sincerely, your husband.
- Link.
- Shanice, lostgirl23 on Twitter said,
"Not mine."
Just to get that outta the way.
"But my parents were," this is kinda
like your Vietnam story, "were
flower girl and page boy."
Now, we'll come back to page boy.
"To the same wedding because my dad
was the nephew of the groomsmen.
And my grandmother was
friends with the bride.
My parents are not related," sweaty emoji,
sweaty laughing emoji, "they only realized
when they got married themselves."
- Okay, so they only realized
when they got married.
There's no connection
between the two families.
- What about page boy, can we go there?
Does page boy mean the ring bearer?
- Ah, I'm gonna say-
- Or do they bring
a pager to this wedding.
- Yeah, I think it's on a pillow,
but it's a pager instead of a ring.
- Because he was a
doctor or a drug dealer?
The guy getting married
was a drug dealer and-
- No, he was just an EMT, he's an EMT.
- He's an EMT.
- I was the ring bearer in
my aunt Teecee's wedding.
- You remember it?
- No, I don't remember it.
Of course, you got all
the wedding pictures
and I had a pillow with the,
I guess both rings were on it.
That's a lot to entrust
like a little child,
young enough to not remember it.
- And also, I'd have trouble
not eating one of the rings,
the way I was at that age.
I would just put things in my mouth.
- I mean, I was like-
- I guarantee you that's-
- I was four years old.
- How many ring bearers-
- I was smart enough-
- swallow the ring
every year.
- Not eat a ring.
- And then they like, "Oh, crap, well,
we have to delay the wedding.
How long does it take
a ring to get through
a toddler's digestive system?
Or do you just have the wedding-
- Write that down.
- And be like,
we'll just do like a temporary ring,
or a pager in this case.
Maybe that's what happened.
- Were you ever a ring bearer?
How many weddings have you
been in, just by the way?
- How many weddings have I in?
- Well, you were in my wedding.
- As a child none.
- I was only in my aunt
Teecee's wedding, I believe.
- My first wedding that I
was in was my brother's.
Which might be the first wedding that,
you weren't in that wedding.
- I wasn't in Cole's wedding.
- You came to it though?
- Well, yeah, I attended
the wedding, I think.
Yeah, it was in Indiana.
- Indiana, we drove to
Chicago, remember that?
- Right, yeah.
- Unauthorized.
- That was awesome.
- We actually drove to Indiana.
- We picked up your granddad.
He was thumbing.
- Well, no.
- I got it backwards.
- My granddad picked us up.
- Yeah, we were hitchhiking.
- We were in Rensselaer, Indiana.
And my grandfather, my dad's
dad, who lived in Michigan.
Who we didn't have the
best of relationships with.
I had seen him maybe once in my life.
He decides that he can make
the drive down to Indiana
to see my brother get married.
And Link and I had driven
a car from North Carolina
to Indiana, at like age whatever we were,
17 at the time.
- 17 probably.
- But then for some
reason, when we got there
we no longer had use of the car
because somebody else was
using it, my dad or Cole,
or somebody.
- Yeah, they needed
the extra car for something.
- And at that point, me and you were like,
let's explore this town.
- We're not stayin' here.
We're not stayin' here at
the rehearsal or whatever.
- Yeah, we drove to Chicago.
We did that.
- Yeah.
- But I'm sayin' other than
the driving to Chicago,
after we got rid of the
car we were walking around
in Rensselaer, Indiana,
and an old man pulls up
and rolls down the window.
And it's my grandfather,
talk about a coincidence.
And I literally have seen
this guy once in my life.
And he's like, you need a ride.
- He knew who you are.
- Yeah, and I was like, "Yeah."
We got in there and he was like,
"I don't know about this town.
It's got more churches
than liquor stores."
- You remember him saying
that, because I was in the car
I don't remember that.
I remember like, wow,
to be Rhett's grandad,
this is kind of a cold-
- His weird interaction.
- Cold relationship.
- I mean, I just didn't know him.
- Yeah.
- But I'll never forget that line.
"I don't know about this town.
There's more churches than liquor stores."
Yeah, that was how he judges
how comfortable he would be with a town.
(Link chuckles)
- Oh man.
And after that, did
you ever see him again?
- I don't know.
Maybe, I don't know.
I don't think so.
I think I saw him twice.
I think I saw him once when
I was probably like 10.
And then once when my brother got married.
- He didn't show up for your wedding?
- He did not.
He did not show up, I've never
even thought really thought.
I mean, we'd literally had
very little relationship with him.
It's not like a broken relationship
that was that I used to
remember him and it was broken.
It was just never, it never happened.
So I don't really think much about it.
- Except for that story.
- What a coincidence.
- Which we do think about occasionally.
- Yeah, right.
- If he wasn't in town for the wedding
that'd be one hell of a coincidence.
(Rhett chuckles)
- Exactly, right, exactly.
Oh, what are you doing here?
But again, I think this
is a really cool story
for your parents and I'm sure your parents
tell this story Shanice, to friends-
- But if you grow up, if
you're connected to people
in a town who get married and then like,
but they didn't realize
it until they got married.
That's what makes it weird.
Like maybe they didn't live in the town,
or they moved away or
something, I don't know.
I'd need more details to by wowed.
- This is not magic.
I mean, I'll ultimately
what we're saying is
this is just a coincidence.
It's cool, it's cute.
And your parents, they
have a really cool story
that they can tell, but it's not magic.
No magic occurred here.
- I think this is a good one.
Jen Everson @jennywhitee or
jennywhitee, I don't know,
double E at the end.
"My husband and I went to the same uni."
Oh, oh, your British is showing.
I don't know where your
non-American use of university.
We don't say uni here.
- No we don't.
- It kind reminds me,
it's like sayin' like,
innie, outtie, or uni.
Like a third type of belly button.
- Right, yeah.
- "My husband and I went to the same uni,
but didn't meet during that time.
Near the start of our relationship,
we were walking past the
house I had last lived in
and he told me he had also lived there,
only five years earlier,
in the same bedroom.
So crazy.
What a small, weird world."
Well, it's not as weird
as if he were to say,
"You know what, I lived
there in this room-"
- And I'm a vampire.
- Under the bed
that you slept in.
- [Rhett] Yeah, right.
- And you just never knew it.
That's pretty cool.
I mean, you get married, you have this,
obviously you found this connection,
you found your soul mate,
and then you realize that
you slept in the same place,
only five years apart.
- I have a theory here that I
think might hold some water.
- Magic?
- It's definitely not
magic, this is all science.
Now, you know having made
an ad for sleep better.org
back in the day, to try to get people
to replace their pillow.
Just how many dead skin
cells a person sheds.
- A lot, okay, okay.
- Recently, I was watching something
and they were talking about
dust, and they were like,
in your house, if you
just go up to a shelf,
like a top shelf that you
haven't been to in a while,
and you run your finger across that dust,
a very high percentage of
that dust, if not most of it,
is dead skin cells from the
people who live in the house.
- Wow!
- Now I just heard that one time
and maybe it's not true that
it's majority, but a lot.
The amount of pounds of skin
that you shed in a week,
you just are getting rid
of a lot more of yourself
than you realize.
And every nine years,
your entire body is new.
Every single cell in
your body, even the ones
that take a long time to turn
over, like your liver cells.
Everything is new.
- Wow!
- While your husband,
who lived there first?
- He did five years earlier.
- So your husband's
living in this bedroom.
He is just shedding himself
all over the bedroom.
I mean, he will forever,
he's still in that bed.
- He's sheddin' the bed.
He's sheddin' the walls.
He's sheddin' the ceiling.
Your husband is all over this room.
And it's almost like
the essence of husband.
- Might be a different bed.
Definitely not the same bedding.
- No, it's not, he's the walls.
- But the walls,
- Walls, the floor,
definitely the ceiling,
nobody dusts the ceiling.
- Oh.
- And then you go-
- I do.
- Into this room and you live
for some specified period of time.
And we already know-
- Your skin cells
and his skin cells make a skin cell baby.
- That's not what happened.
You can't get pregnant that way.
- It flies around like a fairy
and introduces the two of you-
- See, now you're getting into magic.
Now, here's another
scientific principle at play.
I think we talked about this,
we tried to do an episode
of GMM about this, and it didn't work.
It was one of those experimental episodes
where we had different
people wear different shirts
and then you smelled them
and decided if you were like,
we tried to guess who it was.
But it was based on a
study that had been done,
which is based on people's pheromones
and sort of like just general body odor,
different people are attracted
to different sort of,
for lack of a better word
flavor profiles of other people.
- I don't think that was science.
I think it was just some
person who we had on the show,
who said they could do
a personality profile
based on what people smelled like.
- That was different.
- Okay.
- But no, but, no, 'cause
there was a study that was done
where it was like, okay, say
if me, as a heterosexual man
who is attracted to women,
were to smell 10 women's shirts
that they had worn, and I
ranked them according to
which smell I was most attracted to.
If you were then to show me those women,
I would be more likely to order them
in my level of attraction
to them, based on the smell.
That's what the study
kinda in general said.
- Huh.
- So, what I'm saying is that,
I believe that Jen-
- We almost did an episode of GMM
called Do White People Smell Like Cheese?
- We did, we did.
- That was pitched to
us, but we never did it.
- We decided against that.
- Spoiler alert.
We do.
- We do.
Jen, what happened in your situation
is your husband has shed in the room.
And you breathed him in
over the course of the time
that you lived there.
And whether or not you had a
natural connection with that,
just exposure therapy, being
exposed to the leftover husband
that is in that room over the course
of the time you lived
there, you became primed-
- Developed an affinity.
- Yes.
It's just like when you're tryin'
to get rid of a peanut allergy
and you give a little
bit of peanut to a person
over a period of time.
So now, it's like her
husband is the peanut.
She doesn't have an allergy to him,
but in the same way that you
can get rid of an allergy,
you can enhance an attraction.
And that is precisely and scientifically
and definitively what
happened in this case.
And that is why you're together today.
- I actually wonder if it's the opposite.
I wonder if she was still,
well, if she was still living in the room
when they started dating,
he would have known that.
- I was hopin' you would back me up here.
- I am gonna back you up
because my road dead ended.
I'm gonna be very-
- Fairly quickly.
- I'm just gonna be very specific.
I mean, I don't know if it's skin cells,
but like-
- Oh it is.
I think it's like, even if
it was like a scent thing,
then when she's like, there's
somethin' about that room,
that like a part of him made
the room smell a certain way.
And then five years later,
maybe it's still smelled that way.
And then he smelled, she
smells him in real life later,
and it makes that.
It's a comforting connection.
- She smelled seashells by the seashore.
(Link chuckles)
- We got some other good ones.
Don't makin' any magic.
- Definitely enhanced their connection.
- Let's talk about this
Mythical grooming collection,
because we cannot forget.
We've totally revamped the
Mythical grooming collection.
There's so much stuff
that it all can't fit
in the high-quality canvas toiletry bag
that is available at mythical.com.
But if you go inside of this thing,
talk about lovely scents.
This hand lotion has a subtle version
of the Mythical Number Nine cologne scent.
And every time I see
this, I gotta put it on,
'cause I love, it's a unisex scent.
Oh man, this is not open, I gotta open it.
- Now you already know
that we got the beard oil,
which is now in new packaging,
but it's the same formula.
We have added to the
beard line, beard balm,
which has got a little bit
of, I think we added some-
- Magic?
- There's some bees wax.
Yeah, we added some
bees wax to the formula,
so that it does the same thing
to moisturize your beard,
but also kinda helps you shape it.
Still got the oil.
- We got the Mythical pomade
and now we've come out with
a Mythical clay pomade,
which for my hair that works perfectly.
And we've got the purely perfect
peanut butter peppermint lip balm.
But now we've introduced a new lip balm.
- We phased out the wood
and berries lip balm,
because let's just be
honest, it wasn't great
unless you like the taste
of wood in your mouth.
- Candy milk is a great taste.
- So it's a little bit more
palatable to the average palate.
- Yes, it's so-
- Speakin' of which-
- Sweet and milky.
- This wet and dry comb,
brush, Mythical brush,
it's made from wood guys.
This isn't plastic, this is wood.
- The Mythical comb is plastic
and it plays a tune because it is musical.
It plays the GMM theme song.
(Link scats)
Which part of it-
- It plays the first half.
- Yeah, I'm gonna give it a try.
Ah, I'm not good at it yet.
(comb clicks)
- Yeah, it takes a couple
tries to get it down.
(Rhett laughs)
You're putting so much-
- You try it.
- Putting so much pressure on it.
- You practiced more than me.
I mean, it's an instrument,
it takes some practice.
(comb clicks)
(Link chuckles)
- You can get even better.
Go to mythical.com.
Here, put that in the slot.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, hee hoo.
- That was a lot harder.
- Worth the wait.
- Mythical.com, get yourself groomed up.
Okay, Jo Scott.
"I only ever washed my first car twice.
Both times I did this
I had minor accidents
three days later.
I've never hand washed a car ever again."
- Now this is not a coincidence,
this is a superstition.
This is different.
This is a superstition.
It's a correlation, but
it's not a coincidence
because you did somethin'
and then somethin' happened
three days later.
A coincidence is when
like things come together
that are completely out of your control
and that you can't ritualize it.
It's superstition.
- I agree, but when was the
last time you hand washed a car?
Have you hand washed any cars?
- Not in LA.
I don't think I've ever
hand washed a car in LA, no.
There's so many car washes around.
It's like it's part of the economy.
- Agreed.
- Back home, I mean, with
the water restrictions,
they wouldn't let you
just hose down your car.
You can only wash your car
certain days of the week.
And I'm like, "Well, screw it.
I just won't wash my car."
Unless I'm getting somebody
else to do it correctly.
I mean, I don't wanna get in an accident
three days later either, by the way.
- I've hand washed, I've
probably hand washed my car
four times since being in LA.
- Do you have a brush?
- Yeah, I went on Amazon
and bought like a little
like $20 kit.
That was like a bucket for like the thing.
- Do you like the idea
of washin' your own car?
- No, there was a specific,
oh, I know what it was.
I know what it was.
- What?
- I went to one of the normal washers.
- Okay.
- And some of the drive-through washers,
and then some are you pull up
and you do the spray
and you kind of dial in
and it's got the brush that
the soap comes out of it.
And then you spray it off.
But both of those, both times,
because they never get completely dry.
And this was like on a new car.
I got those-
- Water spots.
- And you can see, my car is
gray, but it's a dark gray.
Your car is like light tan
or whatever the color is.
You probably got water spots,
you just can't see 'em.
Those water spots drove me crazy.
And I was just like, "Well,
I'll just wash it again."
And I go back and wash it again.
I was like, maybe it was just
something about not drying.
Oh, same thing happened again.
And then I'm goin' online
and they're like well-
- You have to dry it.
- Yeah, I know you have to dry it,
but you have to hand dry it.
- Yeah, I mean, yeah.
So you bought a whole kit,
just so you could hand dry?
- No, I had to wash the car
to get the water spots off.
- So you bought a whole kit
to wash the water spots off?
- And then I was out there and I was like-
- It didn't help.
- No, it did.
And I was like, "This is kinda fun."
Playin' some music, kind of
felt like a California guy.
You know what I'm sayin',
like out in the driveway.
- It's an American movie type-
- And I was very conscious of
the amount of water I used.
I didn't use that much water.
But I also, I'll pass on this
unsolicited piece of advice.
I didn't understand how important it was
for the temperature, for it
to not be too hot and sunny
when you're washin' your car.
I know it seems like somethin'
a California guy wouldn't say.
But if it's in the 90s
and you wash your car,
water spots all day long.
Because you can't get it off fast enough.
You need to wait until it's in the 70s,
and you definitely need to
do it in the late evening
or early morning, when the sun is not
shining directly on that stuff,
so it doesn't dry immediately.
That changed my world.
- I don't remember seeing so
many car washes back home.
But out here, yeah, you
would go through the thing
and then there'll be the hand wash part.
And then you there's
like a swarm of people
that just hand dry the whole car.
- Yeah, you're talking about takin' it
to one of those places
that you get out of the car
and it's driven through and
then somebody drives it.
Yeah, I've done that for sure.
Because the ones that,
like at the gas station
that you drive through, don't go to that.
- No.
- I'm not sayin' don't go to that
because of the thing people worry about
with like their paint job.
I don't care about my paint job.
But I'm just sayin' that
the drying is important.
- And there wasn't even
a coincidence involved.
C.V. Films @technoboys652.
"Once I was drivin' in this parking lot
and got cut off, forcing me into a curb,
which popped my tire.
I start driving away and
realize that the tire's popped."
I like how you're usin' the term popped.
Popped the tire.
"So I pull across the street
into a small parking lot
to inspect it.
I looked up and I'd pulled
directly into a tire store."
- This might be magic. (Rhett chuckles)
- Well, that's serendipity.
You pop your tire and then you,
I mean, it's kind of like,
I remember the one time
that I was driving back in North Carolina,
I was driving from Holly Springs to Apex,
and I got pulled over by a cop.
And I had to find the right a
bit of curb to pull over on.
And when I finally found it to pull over,
the cop behind me the whole time,
I looked up and it was
the police department.
I was at the police department.
- I'll go straight, just book me now.
- I remember that.
So I know the feeling.
You feel the need to explain.
- That's kind of
a different feeling.
You feel the need to explain.
I didn't mean to, I didn't
even know this was a tire shop.
You know, it's just here I am.
- Well, I think that this
is all about perspective.
You got the guy who has busted
his tire, popped his tire,
who pulls in and he's
like, isn't this awesome,
and this is crazy.
This is crazy that I just
pulled into this tire place.
And the tire guys, who
work at the tire place,
"Oh, there's another guy who thinks
it's a great coincidence
that he popped his tire
on that curb that busts everybody's tire.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- I think they might have spike strips.
They might be drawin'-
- It's intentional.
- Yeah, they might be drawin' people in.
It might be more than just a curb.
You know what I'm saying?
- It wasn't just a curb,
it was sabotage.
- It might be
a tire Ponzi scheme,
- A tire poppin' Ponzi scheme.
- I bet you they didn't do that.
Let's believe the best.
I mean, it is a good feeling.
The thing that did excite me
about talking about coincidences,
coinkydinks large and small
is when you experience it,
there's like this elation.
Oh, I'm at a tire shop,
this is so perfect.
Like this is lined up.
Most of the time it's like inexplicable,
but for it to be so
serendipitously service-oriented
is really nice.
But even when it's just
kinda crazy, like, man,
we were in the same wedding
as kids and now we're married.
It feels cool, it feels cool, right.
- Yeah.
- I mean, do you remember
the main coincidence
that I'd love to hear again
is the wild horses one
and we can get back to the tire guy.
- Okay, the wild horses story.
- Because this one highlights
perfectly the thrill
of experiencing a coincidence.
Like you may not know the meaning,
but you feel like there
should be a meaning
because it's just so
crazy that it happened.
And it's a shared experience
that when you tell it
it's never as good as
when you experienced it.
But it brings up other
people's experiences,
so you, at least you can share in that.
And that's what I want.
- I don't remember what year
it was, let's just say 2005,
because it was in the aughts.
- Okay.
- I'm with my brother-in-law
Chris in a boat
at the North Carolina beach,
specifically in the sound
between Emerald Isle and the mainland,
near Beaufort, North Carolina.
- Okay.
- This is a new boat
that Chris has gotten,
he bought from his brother, I think.
So we're kind of like feeling
like this freedom of like,
man, we got a boat, we can go anywhere
on this intracoastal waterway.
And that's not like an expression
I made up, that's a thing.
So we're in the boat and you know,
the coast of North Carolina
its got the Outer Banks,
but it's not just the
mainland and then like,
a long strip of, there's all kinds of
little islands all around
if you look at the map
of the coast, right?
Some are small, some are big.
There's just a bunch of 'em.
And as we're kind of
goin' through the sound
and I see these little
marsh-covered islands,
some have trees on 'em.
And I'm like, "You know there's an island,
somewhere on the the
coast of North Carolina
that has wild horses on it."
And Chris is like, "No."
And I'm like, "Yeah."
I think it has something to do with maybe
the Spanish came over
here hundreds of years ago
and some horses got out
and now there's like a wild population-
- Undomesticated.
- A herd of wild horses
that live on some island.
I was like, "I don't think
it's anywhere around here.
But there are wild horses somewhere."
So, I mean, we moved on.
We started talkin' about other things.
And then we just start goin',
like he's got the pedal to the metal,
we're just flying through the sound.
You can't hear anything.
We're playin' the radio,
the whole time we've
been playin' the radio,
but we can't hear anything
when you're going full bore.
And we're goin' past this island
and all of a sudden we look to our right
and out from like behind a
tree, this horse comes up,
and like turns sideways so that it's like
we can see the whole horse body.
- Wow.
Like it's displaying
itself to us.
- And what did he say?
- The horse said nothing.
Chris immediately stops accelerating
and the boat slows down
and we're just idling.
And we look at each other
like, what in the world?
And he's like lookin' at me like,
I can't believe this is happening.
Then, because the boat is
no longer making any noise
because we're idling,
we hear the song that
is playing on the radio.
And the song that is
currently playing on the radio
is "Wild Horses" by Rolling Stones.
(Link laughs)
- Crazy man.
That's crazy.
And then do you remember what you did?
You looked at each other wide-eyed right?
And you were like, are we
really here for this, right?
- Yeah, it was mind blowing.
- It's a great feeling.
- It was mind blowing.
- It's a strange mixture of what?
Awe, fear, there's like a
little bit of fear in it, right?
You start to feel like is there meaning?
- You have a choice here.
- Is this a puzzle?
- You have a choice in that moment.
And the human tendency is to
attach meaning to it, right?
- Sure.
- Of course, it is questionable
what the meaning would be.
(Rhett laughs) It's
like, well what is the,
what is the lesson from the universe here?
Am I supposed to let write
a letter to Keith Richards?
I don't know what is the point?
We just kinda reveled in the coincidence.
And also, you know me,
and you're the same way,
I'm also thinking, man, I've
got a hell of a story to tell.
I can't wait 'til we get back home.
- Was it just one horse.
'Cause typically there's
like a whole herd.
- Well, I think we ended
up seeing another one,
like eventually we saw some other ones.
- Sure it wasn't a deer?
- It was a horse and it was
called Shackleford Island.
- And that was it?
- Which is known, yeah,
which is known as having-
- You didn't even know that was it.
And you were just shootin'
the breeze earlier.
Having heard-
- I had heard like a radio
story about it or somethin'.
- But go with me here,
because there is somethin'
to this strange mixture of
emotions associated with
experiencing something,
so wild and so horse-like.
- Well, I think maybe-
- There's a bit of,
there's awe-
- There's a rush.
- And a rush that's almost, it
feels a little bit like fear,
like you're on the edge of
a building kind of a thing.
There's like a physical response to it.
- Well do you think,
and I don't like to be-
- Like dribble pee in your pants.
- I don't want to be overly reductionistic
and to say that, and I know
that there are some people
who try to like point
to the very specific,
like evolutionary advantage that-
- Of meaning-making.
- That led to this.
And I know that there is
a scientific explanation
for the significance and also
the sort of mental response
that we get to coincidence.
Guessing that there's a lion in the bushes
and there being a lion in
the bushes that's good.
Like that helped you survive,
you know what I mean?
That's probably overly simplistic.
But it could have
something to do with that.
That being able to recognize
and attach significance
to seemingly random things
is helpful for your survival.
But it could just also be
that it just is an amazing,
it helps you connect socially.
Because me and my
brother-in-law have this story
that we'll tell.
We will tell if we're in
the right place, right time.
- I mean it is, when Christy
and I were on our van trip,
I think that's, again, I was thinking of,
I think there were wild
burros, like throughout Utah,
Arizona, California, lotsa
little donkeys runnin' around
in those open spaces.
And it reminded me of
the story you just told.
And I was tellin' Christy the story
and I was playing my
Spotify playlist, and-
- The song "Wild Asses" from 2 Live Crew.
- The song "Wild Horses" came on
as I was telling this story
and I had not played it.
I didn't select the playlist
knowing that it was in the playlist.
It was a really long,
automatically-generated playlist.
Yes, I was in '70s classic rock playlist.
- But still, there's a
lot of music in that.
- I mean, we weren't freakin'
out when it happened,
but it it did give me a
little boost, you know?
- Yeah, yeah definitely.
- I think the main thing
is when you experience
a coincidence don't hold back
on the celebration part of it.
- Enjoy it.
- To me that's the thing
like squeeze that lemon,
milk it for all it's worth.
Just really smoosh the teat.
- Well, I think that's why-
- It's fun.
'Cause like when we, we'll do that a lot.
We'll turn things into a coincidence.
- Well, that's what I'm getting at-
- This fortune cookie is tellin' us
what we should do with our careers.
And then our eyes'll
get big and we're like,
"Gah, this is me."
- But I'm talkin' about
more than just that,
'cause we don't, we
were talkin' about this,
we don't remember what
the fortune cookie said,
but we had a significant
fortune cookie experience
at some point. I don't know
if I told this story.
- But not significant enough
to remember.
- But also at the beach
with my wife's family,
not on the same trip,
but with our friend Mike,
that we've been camping with
a number of times.
And we were eating and we
had finished corn on the cob.
And we had all these corn cobs.
- Okay.
- And for some reason we just got the idea
that we were gonna, from the third floor,
the third floor balcony
of this beach house,
we were going to throw corncobs
and try to get them to land
in the middle of the road
between the double yellow line.
- Okay, yeah.
This equals-
- Littering.
- A big pile of corncobs all over a road.
- Unless the first one you throw-
- No.
- Rolls, hits the road,
and rolls and comes to rest
right between the double yellow lines.
- The first-
- The first one I threw.
- The first one Mike threw.
Mike is amazing.
- Mike has been with me for
about four or five weird things
that have happened like that.
But what I'm saying is that-
- You know why?
This is the great thing about Mike.
- Because I knew Mike would
go nuts if it happened.
- Well, but, also earlier than that.
You know what? This is worthwhile.
Like this stupid idea that is
on the edge of impossibility is just,
this is a worthwhile endeavor, you know?
So I'm even celebrating that part of it.
You've got someone around
who's like, you know what?
This is, yeah, this is
what we're gonna do.
And there's something about
if you hold your mouth just right,
it's like you brought
this confidence to it.
I know what the experience
of that corn cob
landing just right, it would be like.
So, I bet you.
I wasn't there, but I
bet you set it up like,
we're gonna throw this.
You know you're inventing something crazy.
It's gonna land parallel,
right in between-
- You're setting something
up that's unlikely.
And so that if it does
happen, it's gonna be awesome.
- That happened on the
first thing is like,
I mean, I assume you
erupted in celebration
for a prolonged period of time.
- Of course we did and then-
- And I also assume you
didn't try it any more.
Or did Mike say, "I'm gonna do it too."
- I can't remember, but more recently,
Mike came to stay with us at
our house we live in currently,
and we're like tellin'
the boys stories about,
I can't remember most of 'em right now.
That's the craziest one.
But we've done things like that.
Usually involving throwing
something at something
to see what would happen.
- I mean, that's a long-standing
tradition, I think.
I think it's from when we were kids.
- Yeah, I did a lotta thing
where I was just like,
I'm gonna throw this rock at this pole
and if I hit it the answer
to this question is yes.
It was kind of my magic eight ball.
- Yeah.
- I did a lot of that,
but we were telling Locke
and Shepherd the story
and then it turned into, okay,
we're gonna throw the
basketball on top of the house.
And it's gonna come down and bounce once
and then bank into the
basket, the basketball goal.
And it did not happen on the first try.
But we committed and we took like an hour
and we finally got it.
And because our roof is terracotta,
so you can't predict the
bounce of the basketball.
- It's got a point though, nature.
- But yeah, so I love
setting that stuff up
just because it's cool.
And for me it's about the connection.
- Yeah.
- That's somebody else.
- Yeah, that's the great thing about-
- If you're just by yourself-
- If it happens by yourself
it's just a little freaky.
- You might connect by telling
a story about it later.
- I got nothin' else to
say about the tire story.
Let's go to Mythical crew members.
I guess Kiko put this to crew members.
Oh, maybe they follow us on Twitter.
I mean, it's not a prerequisite
for working for us.
Do you follow employees?
Because I as a policy don't.
- I have sort of-
- We haven't discussed this.
- I have a general policy
of not following employees,
but I realize that it
wasn't always my policy.
And so there was a time in
which I did follow some people.
And then it's like, if
somebody's been with us
for a really long time,
sometimes I'll be like,
hmm, I think I should.
I don't have a good policy on this
but I probably should just,
I should have a policy.
You don't follow anybody as a policy?
- No, I don't.
- I think my policy is not great
because it can open me up to,
it seems like I'm showin' favoritism.
- Yeah, you gotta go in
there and unfollow people.
Unfollow the people who work for you.
- Okay, all right.
- It's a personal, professional boundary.
But I mean, that being said,
you're still bein' watched.
And I'm talkin' to you
Mythical crew members.
- Oh, yeah, right.
- Annalise producer on
Mythical Kitchen now.
Okay, yeah.
She tweeted a shortened version of this,
but I know the complete story
because I watched the Chase-hosted,
Good Mythical crew
podcast that's exclusively
on the Mythical Society.
And Annalise was one of the producers on,
like people who were fans first
and then became employees,
that's the episode they did.
And I really got a kick outta that.
But she tells a story of,
and I'm gonna mess it up.
I'm pretty sure she just moved to LA.
She moved in with a roommate.
She did not know this roommate,
if I remember correctly.
And then she was a fan of ours
and were making that Lionel Richie,
we sing "All Night Long" all night long,
Lionel Richie's "All Night Long."
And at one point, even though
we were filmin' it constantly
for like all 11 hours.
At one point we go into this house party
and there's all these people
that we wanted to come out.
So we put a call out
to fans in the LA area
who wanted to show up at
like 2:00 a.m. at this house
that we were gonna walk through
singing "All Night Long."
And they were gonna start
singin' along with us.
And that's a big scene in the video.
And Annalise is just a fan and she's like,
"Oh wow, I'm just moving in today.
And tonight is when I gotta go."
And she's like, I know this sounds weird.
You're my new roommate.
And she like tells her
roommate that she's like,
I'm fans of these guys,
they're doing this music video.
So I'm gonna be going to this
house party, music video thing
at like 3:00 a.m.
And her roommate's like,
"I'll go with you."
And this was like when they first met.
So they both go.
And yeah, she tweeted, "I
was at Rhett and Link's
"All Night Long" 4:00 a.m.
house party playing a kazoo
and now I work for them."
We did not hire her that night.
We didn't meet her that night,
but you can see her in the music video.
- Somebody had to coordinate
what the crowd would do
when we walked in because we
could not walk, we couldn't-
- Yeah, there were people,
we had someone there
who was like organizing
the crowd and getting them-
- So when we walked in-
- Getting them to rehearse.
Getting them to rehearse and everything.
- Because we left the house,
went into the front yard
and then went out on the street.
- And they followed us down the street.
- In the middle of the
night in this neighbor.
- Yeah, and then we got
in a car and kept goin'.
- I'm sure we made some people mad.
Well, Annalise is in the video, right?
- Yeah.
- If you watch that scene
you can see her in the video.
- And then years later, years later.
- 'Cause that was a long time ago.
- Yeah, she works for us.
- I think that might be magic.
- And she did not tell the
story in her job interview,
which wasn't with us.
So she didn't get any
brownie points for that.
- You know what, it's probably wise to not
tell that kinda story
in your job interview.
- Yeah.
- Like I got a weird call
from Rhett and Link years ago
to show up at a house
at 4:00 a.m. and I did.
- Unless you showed up on a wild horse.
Read Jenna's.
- Yeah, I gotta bring this closer to me
because the text is small.
Jenna, who works for us.
"LOL, I have good coincidence
story the guys might like.
A few years ago, after takin'
a break from assistant work
for about a year, I thought to myself
that I was ready to maybe assist again
if I liked who I worked for.
I didn't tell anyone."
- Didn't tell anyone.
- "The next day, my best
friend Laura, texted me
about these two men
(both chuckle) whose hair
and makeup she was doing for their show,
talking about needing an assistant.
She threw my name out there.
Those men were Rhett and Link."
- What!
- First of all, I just appreciate
she's sayin' those men.
We get called boys a
lot and sometimes guys.
Those men Rhett and Link.
- Well, that's part of
her job requirement.
- Yeah, we told her
that she has to call us-
- Remember one of the
first things you told her,
is that always refer to us as men.
- The men.
- 'Cause somebody needs
to. (Link chuckles)
- Well, this is a coincidence
that I'm very glad it worked out, in fact-
- I mean, she didn't tell anybody.
She didn't even tell Laura-
- In her job interview,
well, first of all,
she was recommended by
Laura, who we trusted
and spent a lot of time with.
And especially when it
comes to having someone
who's gonna be-
- Touch your face.
- Well, I was gonna move beyond that,
say somebody who's
gonna be your assistant.
There's got to be the ability to kind of
click with them personally.
- Yeah.
- Not only they have to
be good at their job,
but you need to be able
to get along with them.
And Laura just kind of saw, she was like,
you know who would be perfect for this?
And so that did a lot to kinda
prepare us for liking Jenna.
And then her job interview was essentially
coming to the Mythical
Christmas party that year.
- She was Laura's date-
- As Laura's plus one.
- Yeah.
And of course, I felt a
little bit awkward about
turning meeting her at this
party into her interview.
But of course, you didn't.
- No, I didn't. (Rhett laughs)
I was like, what else am I gonna do here?
- So we kind of conducted the interview.
- Let's get this over with.
- In a loud bar, where there
was a guy in the corner
doing bonsai, because we
thought that would be funny.
- It was kinda nice because I mean,
Christy was there for it
and then Christy ended up
talkin' to her and Laura more.
And so it was like-
- Because Jessie and Christy
needed to also like Jenna.
- Yeah, that's true.
- 'Cause she was gonna
be working with them too.
And it all worked out
- But I didn't know that
Jenna wasn't looking
for an assistant job until like,
in her mind the day before.
- Right.
- And you know what, it's worked out.
Kiko producer of this podcast,
who's sitting behind in
the glass booth over there.
"Four years ago, it was the Friday
before I was gonna start
my new job at Mythical,
I had the day off, so I
hit up my college friend
of 10 years to see if
she wanted to hang out.
She told me that she was
waiting for a meeting
with this company that she
had been freelancing for
for the past few weeks.
And she was gonna find
out if she was going to be
brought on full time.
I got really excited and told her
I was gonna start a new job on Monday too.
I asked what company
to which she responded,
Mythical Entertainment.
- Mythical Entertainment.
Although Meggie and I have
had many jobs together,
this was the first where we
both got hired separately
without the other knowing.
Somehow we can't seem to
get rid of each other."
Yeah, Kiko will throw Meggie into a story.
Meggie was in Kiko's ghost story.
- A magic story too.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Lots of powers at work in Kiko's-
- Well I would say, the
based on the precedent
of the ghost story that I can't just
dismiss this as coincidence.
There could be something
cosmic going on here.
- I think that we just
put out job postings
and like they're friends
and they apply for
- the same stuff.
- Ah, don't minimize it.
Don't minimize it.
- Come on, Kiko, this is not.
I mean, like you said, you
worked together a lot before.
This is the first time you didn't know it.
This is not-
- Yeah but think about it
the name of the company.
- This is just-
- The name of the company
is Mythical Entertainment.
- Okay, okay.
- That alone it gets you
to thinkin' a little bit.
- You're right.
Two men.
- There's two men who run it.
(Link chuckles)
- Two men.
(Rhett laughs)
- WillowHub.
I'm sorry, Kiko,
You know what?
That was pretty awesome.
- I think is awesome.
- WillowHub tweeted at us.
"Once I got a piece of
paper and wrote down
what I would say if I was a teacher."
I don't know if that's-
- But the specifics
have not been provided.
- I don't know if that's
a result of an assignment
or like a prompt.
"That class period, the
teacher copied my exact words.
It was almost like she
was reading my paper."
But of course she couldn't
because I still had it, I guess.
"I freaked out, and the
recess, I was super nervous.
And then at home I puked on the paper."
- Okay.
All right, there's a lot here.
Lots of movin' parts.
- Wrote down what she would
say if she was a teacher.
Then the teacher just says
what she's written down.
- I'm having a difficult time getting past
just the first part of the story-
- Yeah, writin' down.
- So like, okay.
I'm just tryin' to picture this.
You are-
- Moving on.
You wanna just move? (Rhett chuckles)
- No, no, so-
- You're not gonna figure it out.
- You got a piece of paper
and you write down what you
would say if you were a teacher.
- And then her teacher said that.
- But, I can't get past point one.
What is happening there?
- If that's an assignment, what
kind of assignment is that?
It's like the teacher's
like, you know what?
- If it's an assignment,
then that makes more sense.
- I want all of you
to write down what you
think a teacher would say,
so psychically I can steal it
and it makes my job easier.
- If it was an assignment,
then the chances of coincidence
go up significantly, right?
Because, I don't know what grade this was.
I can imagine what a 10th grader
might think a teacher would say.
No, if this is just a person,
who is just deciding on their own
to just begin to write down things
that teachers might say,
what's goin' on there?
- Yeah, that's-
- Have you ever done
anything like that?
Have you ever just said, you know what?
I wonder what a so-and-so might say-
- I'm gonna write that down.
- Down on a sheet of paper.
- Never, but maybe I should.
Especially if I find
that I have control over
what then someone in that occupation says.
I wonder what the president would say?
- Here's the thing WillowHub.
If it was a magic piece of
paper that you puked on it
and you ruined it, that
coulda been the beginning
of you living an incredible life,
where you could write things
on this paper and then-
- Manifest.
- Manipulate
what people would say.
And you just went home
and puked on the paper.
And presumably then tossed it.
That may have been your chance to live
an incredible, magical life.
- Or just to be like a script writer.
'Cause that's kind of
what a script is.
- Everything they say
is somethin' that then happens.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- That's what makes me-
- That's your calling Willow.
- So awesome.
- Good luck with your
stomach issues though.
I just, you know what?
I think this is a good stopping point.
- No, I think we have
to read the last one.
- I feel like I'm gonna puke.
- We have to read the last one.
- We gotta read-
- Somethin' about
the gunk in the bottom of
this stuff I've been drinking.
- No, we have to read the
last one because this is the-
- I think you just wanna
say brokeback bitch.
- That is the name of the
Twitter account brokeback bitch.
- Okay.
- I was calling you brokeback bitch.
- Fine, I call you that too all the time.
- "Years ago, planning to
intern far from home that summer
I decided to rent a room online.
A few weeks before I left,
I had a very vivid
dream about being there.
When I arrived, I had a
strong feeling I've been
in the room before, but shook
it off thinking of the dream.
I assume the photos from the
listing informed the dream,
but there were other details in the dream
that weren't in the photos.
For example, I opened,"
and this is all in the dream,
"I opened the nightstand drawer
and saw a specific book, tangled earbuds,
folded pieces of paper and a Q-tip."
- Used?
- Doesn't say.
"When I was moving in weeks later,
I opened the nightstand
to put my things away
inside was that same
book, tangled ear buds,
pieces of paper,"
- Q-tip?
- "and Q-tip in the exact
same positions as my dream.
It creeped me the hell out
and I still don't know
what to make of it."
- And that was the day that
I became brokeback bitch.
(Rhett laughs)
- The brokeback bitch origin story.
- Yeah, I think he's
definitely a super hero.
- But what's the power?
The power to predict
what will be in a drawer.
- I don't know.
It's like, there's definitely
a wild horse involved.
No saddle.
- That's true.
I see, you keep bringin'
it back to wild horses.
- I haven't seen the movie,
but I guess there's like
I don't know, I don't know.
Somebody's gay, I think.
- I think at least two guys, two men.
There's something here, okay.
There's something here.
Now, four objects
positioned in a certain way.
- I'm just caught up on like open,
I don't like the idea of openin' a drawer
and seein' a Q-tip.
Even if you can't tell it's been used.
- But it's a dream Q-tip.
- No, but then it was real.
and that's the weirdest part.
- But it came from a dream though.
- Like why do you have one
Q-tip in a bedside drawer?
That's disturbing.
Unless it was like coated in plastic,
like in a plastic baggie or somethin'.
- Do you think this happened?
Let me just ask you that.
- Leave me behind in Q-tip land
and keep goin' with the conjecture
because I don't know what to do with this.
- Well, there are two, there's
a number of possibilities,
but the two ones that
I see are number one,
everything happened as brokeback bitch
has said it did, right?
Meaning that this was the
dream in the position.
And then she saw in the
drawer, these specific things.
What are the chances that
that is exactly what happened?
Now, I'm not questioning
brokeback bitch's integrity here,
because I do believe that brokeback bitch-
- Is being honest.
- Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm just kinda sayin' I'm giving her
the benefit of the doubt.
'Cause the other explanation
is that in the moment
of seeing the stuff inside the drawer,
she sort of projected
what she's seeing now
back onto the memory as she accessed it
and accessed it in a way that made it seem
as if they were the same.
Scientifically, I don't know.
- I think that's possible.
I think, I mean,
if there was a purpose to it
or there was some redemptive application
and that kept me from, you
know, blah, blah, blah, blah,
or enabled me to blah, blah, blah, blah.
Or was the first sign
of my psychic abilities
through dreams.
- Or is there something
about the specific book,
which again all we see is-
- Devoid of purpose-
- Is it just a specific book
or what is the specific book?
Should you have taken action?
Should you have taken the
tangled earbuds, unplug them,
plug them directly into
the end of the Q-tip.
Maybe something would have played.
- I would have cleaned out
my ears with the Q-tip,
then put the earbuds in
and read the book.
- Read the book.
And then used the folded pieces of paper
to take notes on the book.
- But when you think about, I mean,
what I didn't wanna get to
was what I'm about to say.
- Well, good.
- There's so many, you know,
anything that can happen
in some point across all
parallel universes does happen.
All the coinkydink, miraculous
things that line up,
it's just like odds,
like statistics dictate
that it's gonna happen.
I don't know, the more you study evolution
the more you start to think that,
I think about that analogy
of all these monkeys
typin' on a keyboard.
And if you have enough monkeys typin'
then you're gonna get Shakespeare.
Is that what it is?
- Yeah, but I don't know if that,
I don't know if that's true or not.
(Link laughs)
- Okay.
- I'm not smart enough to figure it out.
- Can you dream random things in a drawer
and then it just, you
know, it could happen.
It could be a total coincidence.
Could it mean somethin' more to you
and it could be an
indication of some sort of
prescient knowledge.
- Well, I have a dream coincidence.
- But there's no purpose to it.
- I've told the story before.
- Does there need to be purpose to it?
- I'm probably gonna
get the details wrong.
I've probably told this
story like three times now,
but you know the story about my wife and I
dreaming about the same
little blonde girl.
- Yes, yes, the little blonde girl.
- And then waking up at
the same time, freaked out.
And both of us having just had a nightmare
that featured this little blonde girl.
In my situation, she was in an elevator,
or she was in a room that
an elevator opened up into.
I can't remember Jesse's situation.
I told the story more
detailed in the past.
And I don't know, me and
Jesse were pretty freaked out
for a couple of days.
But that was kind of the,
again, that's sort of the end of it.
- If it didn't keep happening-
- I never ran into a little blonde girl.
- It wasn't a revelation of
something, some connection
or some ability or-
- Well, but I do think
that I am open to the idea.
First of all, again, I don't
wanna be overly reductionistic.
I am open to the idea
that there is something,
that dreams are not just simply your brain
sort of rearranging itself
and shuffling through your
thoughts as you sleep.
Is that the most likely
thing that's happening?
Yeah, but who cares?
Who's interested in most likely, right.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Is it really fun to just believe
the most likely thing for everything?
Or is it more fun to
believe that I don't know,
there's some kinda connection between
the real world and the dream world.
And some people have
some insight into that.
And let's lean into that.
Who's gonna get hurt if we
lean into that a little bit.
I'm interested in that.
I mean, you got the way that the sort of
the native people from Australia
and the way that they
experience the dream world.
And I haven't looked into this very much,
but it's very, very significant.
It's essentially sort
of like the foundation
of the religion as far as I understand
is the fact that there's this dream world.
I don't know, maybe
brokeback bitch broke through
into the dream sphere.
And we're just sitting here
on a podcast talkin' about it,
makin' light of it, sayin'
that is probably just
she went back and accessed a memory,
and made it up in her mind.
Well maybe brokeback
bitch broke through, man.
Maybe that's what happened.
- Who are we to say.
- Do you believe?
Okay, fine, magic.
- I'm open to it.
But I have never been scared
by a little blonde girl
in real life.
- Or in your dream again.
- She hasn't come back to
the dreams for either of us.
- If you would have responded
to our prompt on Twitter
using hashtag EarBiscuits,
we could have been talkin'
about you this episode.
So be on the lookout for those.
Follow us on Twitter @mythical.
We're gonna keep puttin' out
these things periodically
where you can give us stuff to talk about.
And then if you wanna keep talkin' to us
and respond to this,
use hashtag EarBiscuits.
- Do you have a rec for us?
- Oh, crap, I forgot about the rec.
It's a show on Netflix that like,
Lily gets into all this murder stuff.
And of course I never
got on the murder wave.
I never got on the murderer
or the serial killer wave.
I'm not into that.
That's too hard hitting for me.
But I did agree to sit down and watch
because Lily talked Christy into watching
"I Am A Killer"-
- Yeah, the interviews.
- On Netflix, where they interview people
who are committed murderers
and they tell their stories.
The approach to it is
mesmerizing and very creepy,
but also very insightful.
I'm gonna recommend
episode one of season two
because they were talking about it so much
that I had to go watch it.
Now it's not for everybody.
And if you're not into,
if you don't wanna stare
into the dark soul of a
killer through her eyes.
Actually I quoted it last
week when I was talkin' about,
well I'm not, I don't wanna spoil it here.
I'm not gonna tell you the specific quote,
'cause it kinda spoils the experience.
- Okay.
- We've watched a number of the episodes,
but an amazing presentation
of this particular
convicted murder's story
in the way that it unfolds.
It really draws you in and
gets you to assess it yourself
and come to your own conclusions.
That's kinda how the series is set up.
I don't know that you
wanna watch all of 'em
unless you're really into
the psyche of murderers.
But the first one of
season two is really great.
That isolated episode in and of itself
is just worth watching.
- You're really buildin' it up.
- Yeah, it's wild.
- "I Am A Killer," by no coincidence.
- On Netflix.
- All right, we'll talk to you next week.
- [Link] To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(upbeat music)